mel gibson's biblical drama The Passion
of the Christ
both divided and shocked audiences
nationwide after its release in 2004
regardless it received three Academy
Award nominations and remains the
highest-grossing r-rated film of all
time on screen The Passion of the Christ
has its fair share of bizarre moments
like the part where Satan carries around
a baby Voldemort Mel Gibson purposely
added those uncanny valley moments just
to catch audiences off-guard saying
that's what evil is about taking
something that's good and twisting it a
little bit but as surreal as things can
get during the movie itself there were
even more bizarre happenings behind the
scenes some of which you might not even
believe electrifying work according to
one study lightning strikes roughly 240
thousand people per year in other words
it's fairly rare but in 2003 it happened
three times on the set of The Passion of
the Christ lead actor Jim Caviezel
claimed he was lit up like a Christmas
tree while filming the Sermon on the
Mount sequence of the film you get
struck with lightning I was struck by
lightning light came right down from
heaven and let me up what people
witnessed was an illumination around my
body and a fire on the right and left
side of my head but he wasn't the only
person on the set to get struck Caviezel
added five minutes after I got hit John
McCauley me an assistant walks over and
says are you okay and then he got hit
the difference was that they saw the
bolt come down and hit John all I felt
was this giant tremendous slap on my
ears in a few seconds of a pink-red
static in front of my eyes
unbelievably that wasn't even the first
time the assistant director had been
struck on set according to BBC News
lightning had already struck his
umbrella luckily only causing light
burns on his fingertips whiplash
because you can't actually beat to your
film star in real life
a hidden whipping post was set up behind
Caviezel while filming The Passion of
the Christ notoriously bloody scourging
scene the problem was one of the actors
doing the flogging didn't have the best
aim Caviezel recalled - today he's
lashed just extended over the board and
hit me with such a velocity that I
couldn't breathe I turned around and
looked at the guy and I tell you I may
be playing Jesus but I felt like Satan
at that moment a couple of expletives
came out of my mouth not that it helped
moments later Caviezel accidentally
received another blow ouch
cross-purposes not only did Caviezel get
struck by lightning and accidentally
whipped
he also dislocated his shoulder while
carrying the film's massive crucifix
Caviezel shoulder popping out of place
was just the start of his misery between
the frigid cold and strong winds during
the crucifixion scenes the actor also
got a lung infection and pneumonia my
mouth was shaking uncontrollably my arms
and legs went numb I was suffocating on
that cross but hey at least he didn't
get migraines right he got migraines to
add icing on top of Caviezel cake of
pain the actor regularly suffered severe
migraines from working day in and day
out with one eye cosmetically swollen
shut according to today Caviezel had to
head into work at 2:00 a.m. every day in
order to provide enough time for the
film's makeup artist to cover him in
cosmetic bruises cuts lashes and fake
blood they also had to arrange his crown
of thorns and seal one eye shut which
wreaked havoc on his depth perception he
told Fox News you're going to work every
day with only one eye functioning which
gives you headaches and you thought I
strain from your office job was bad
dramatic conversion filming The Passion
of the Christ had a pretty profound
effect on many people involved in the
production and the film set became the
site of some religious conversions
father John bar tunic who hung out on
set told National Catholic Register
everyone felt comfortable talking about
issues of faith
being a priest in the midst of that I
was like a lightning rod for spiritual
conversations fortunately in this case
he didn't mean an actual lightning rod
one actor who became a Christian on set
was Luca Leonel Oh the actor who plays
Judas bar tunic explained he asked for
confession apparently he had been
completely transformed by the experience
he baptized his children sanctified his
marriage and came back to the church
naturally not everyone who worked on the
set of The Passion of the Christ
experienced a religious Epiphany but
most people were affected in one way or
another Caviezel told the 700 club all
the actors that worked on this film it
will stay with them the rest of their
lives people will always come up to them
people will always ask them about the
movie they were in it will always be
with them career wrap during the filming
of The Passion of the Christ Caviezel
had to endure a lot of pain and freak
accidents but the bad luck didn't end
there Caviezel has since claimed that
he's been blackballed by Hollywood for
playing Jesus in fact he recalled Gibson
trying to talk him out of it because of
the effect it would have on his career a
truly great remarkable man oh thank you
very much Ron that's very kind of you
Jesus Christ is here with me still
Caviezel 'he's career might be due for a
resurrection with the actor set to
reprise his most famous role in Gibson's
upcoming sequel to The Passion it's a
sequel to The Passion of the Christ is
that true it's probably about three
years off because it's a big subject
yeah yeah I've read the book Caviezel
also described the project to USA Today
saying I won't tell you how he's going
to go about it but I'll tell you this
much the film he's going to do is going
to be the biggest film in history it's
that good with so many bizarre
happenings taking place on the set of
the original we can only imagine what's
in store for the sequel although we're
definitely hoping for fewer lightning
strikes thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]